[Music]  72 megan  you beat him  ah it's like the  mathematics of like eyes to nose to  mouth to head with height ratio he did  it on stern and they were saying that  like brad pitt's like a 92 or something  you know  oh so it actually does bear out if you  pointed at a george clooney or uh i  guess yeah your head is close to the  perfect ratio megan your eyes are nearly  the perfect distance apart they're  slightly too small for your head  i'm always saying that it's kind of  gross  um  you have a slightly narrow mouth for  your face you got things just saying  what we've all been thinking yeah do you  want to do it  sure you're too scared i'm not so scared  i know this isn't going to go well  i was a 45  i think hair way too big for your head  error  smoke is coming out of your stop now  there's only so much i can do  [Applause]  it says i look a lot like conan o'brien  congratulations  oh  usually that's a curse